[музыка]
делая это и лень и прокрастинации
исчезнут Если вы не освоите эти правила
и техники то ваша жизнь превратится в
Унылое существование досмотрите это
видео до конца и вы возьмёте контроль
над своей жизнью в свои руки Никто из
вас наверное не будет спорить что
уровень нашей жизни напрямую
определяется уровнем наших достижений но
ни одно наше достижение невозможно без
активной деятельности враг всех наших
достижений - это прокрастинация и лень
сегодня мы говорим о том как победить
лень и
прокрастинацию это извечная проблема с
которой сталкивается Каждый из нас даже
самые успешные люди миллиардеры
спортсмены творцы каждый борется с ленью
особенно в моменты когда мотивация
пропадает и кажется что ничего уже не
хочется делать Но существуют
определённые способы как с этим
справиться и сегодня я поделюсь с вами
простыми но мощными инструментами
которые помогут вам побеждать
Прости раз за разом Почему лень это не
всегда плохо первое с чего я хочу начать
это осознание того что лень сама по себе
не является чем-то исключительно
негативным лень - это сигнал от вашего
подсознания что вы находитесь не на том
пути или что вам может быть требуется
отдых или быть может у вас какие-то
проблемы со здоровьем очень важно
понимать природу своей лени И
прокрастинации Т механизмом Например
если вы физически или эмоционально
истощены то ваш организм буквально
кричит вам остановись ты
перетрут нами стоит задача которую нам
просто не хочется делать когда
прокрастинация начинает побеждать И
кстати прокрастинация что вы знали это
младшая сестра Лени вот здесь и важно
разобраться как это преодолеть и не
позволить Лени управлять вашей жизнью
Итак важно понимать что у Лени и
прокрастинации есть всего три причины
первое у вас что-то не так со здоровьем
это может быть гормональное нарушение
или потеря энергии вследствии
какого-либо нарушения или болезни второе
вы устали или перетрут И вам требуется
отдых третье ваша цель не настолько
значима для вас вот три причины всё
других вариантов нет первую причину я не
буду затрагивать Она хоть и важная но
встречается не так часто как другие
поэтому первую причину причину лений и
прокрастинации я оставлю на усмотрение
врачей со второй причиной вы сами
прекрасно можете справиться для этого
достаточно хорошенько выспаться
отдохнуть отвлечься или развеяться и всё
вы как огурчик Вы снова готовы
сворачивать горы самой распространённой
и самой негативной для нас является
третья причина это когда мы знаем что мы
здоровы мы не уставшие но в то же время
мы не хотим делать то что нужно Причём
заметьте здесь речь не идёт о любимом
деле Потому что когда человек занимается
любимым делом у него никогда не бывает
прокрастинации и лений я например ещё ни
разу не встречал такого человека который
ленился бы заниматься своим любимым
делом Вот таких людей Обычно другая
проблема Как
остановиться так вот ле про доставляет
нам беспокойство и проблемы тогда когда
нам нужно выполнить задачу которую
необходимо сделать несмотря на то любим
мы этим заниматься или нет все мы знаем
что в жизни не может быть такого что всё
чем вы занимаетесь является любимым
занятием есть много вещей которые мы
попросту должны делать независимо от
того любим мы это или нет так вот
Сегодня я хочу поговорить с вами как раз
о том как побороть лень и прокрастинацию
и выполнять такие задачи Итак Прим
для начала дам вам технику Как начать
что-то делать техника называется 5
секунд не Дайте мозгу шанса на лень это
очень мощная техника которая помогает
преодолеть лень или лень начала любого
дела или откладывание выполнения задачи
буквально за несколько секунд как она
работает очень просто как только вам в
голову приходит мыс Что нужно что-то
сделать тут же начинает или пытается
найти отговорки Почему этого делать Не
стоит так вот помните что у вас есть
всего 5 секунд чтобы начать действовать
прежде чем мозг убедит вас отложить это
дело например вы сидите на диване и
думаете что нужно начать работу над
проектом мозг тут же говорит Ну это
сложно это
долго сделаю это позже в этот момент вы
начинаете отсчёт 5 4 3 2 1 и просто
встаёте и начинаете действовать
это Удивительно но этот метод работает
Попробуйте В следующий раз когда лень
возьмёт вверх и вы удивитесь как легко
Можно перейти от бездействия к действию
второй приём сила маленьких шагов Как вы
думаете что объединяет всех успешных
людей сила воли
дисциплина я вам скажу нет их всех
объединяет две вещи первое умение делать
маленькие конкретные шаги каждый день и
второе привычка достигать целей звучит
просто но это очень
действенно Давайте разберём первое
умение а именно умение делать маленькие
конкретные шаги каждый день этот
инструмент называется сила маленьких
шагов именно на этом построена вся
философия кайзен почему это работает и
почему это эффективно когда мы начинаем
думать о больших задачах наш мозг не
может просчитать весь обм работы и весь
обм рисков изза этого возникает
неопределённость которая вызывает у нас
страх мы видим перед собой огромную гору
работы риски которые мы не можем
просчитать и Но наш мозг автоматически
находит тысячи причин чтобы отложить это
дело на потом Но если разбить эту задачу
на маленькие части и начать с малого наш
мозг начинает работать иначе Я вывел
правило Чем мельче проще и понятнее
задача тем легче и быстрее мы за неё
берёмся Если Вы посмотрите на себя со и
проанализируете Как ваш мозг выбирает
задачи то вы с удивлением обнаружите что
ваш мозг всегда стремится выполнять
неважные задачи А те что попроще
понятнее и легче Представьте что вам
нужно написать книгу Если вы будете
думать о том что вам нужно написать 300
страниц
текста лень прокрастинация начнут начнут
брать вверх Но если поставить себе цель
писать всего одну страницу в день задача
покажется намного легче
и вот через год у вас уже есть книга
поэтому дам вам простой совет каждый
день делайте один маленький Шаг к своей
цели Ну начните хотя бы с 10 минут
работы над задачей которую вы
откладываете помните быстро это медленно
но без остановок Если вы хотите больше
узнавать о таких инсайта и узнавать о
том как применять их в жизни Если вы
хотите узнать больше конкретных
инструментов то обязательно
подписывайтесь на на мой Telegram канал
мои подписчики в моём Telegram канале
первыми узнают о всех таких лайфхаках И
я уверен Вы можете оказаться среди них
ссылку я оставлю в описании к этому
видео внизу давайте рассмотрим второе
умение успешных людей силу привычек Дело
в том что успешные люди - это те люди
которые превратили достижение цели в
привычку привычка - это ваш главный
союзник привычки - это настоящие
антидоты против лени прокрастинации
Знаете есть такая известная фраза мы -
это наши привычки и это действительно
так человек не рождается с привычками
они формируются с течением времени Если
вы хотите узнать С каких привычек Я
начинаю каждый свой день у меня на
канале есть видео которое я снял
специально на эту тему после просмотра
этого видео переходите туда ссылку я
оставлю внизу хорошая новость для нас в
том что привычки можно создавать
осознанно так вот как только вы Пойте
что именно привычки управляют вашими
действиями вы получите мощный инструмент
учёные по-моему гарвардского
университета провели исследование и они
сказали что человек в течение дня до
90-95 про всех своих дел или действий
выполняет на основе привычек Задумайтесь
над этой информацией Итак Как
формируются привычки для формирования
привычки Нужно понять механизм
формирования привычки А он такой причём
не имеет значения В какой сфере вы
хотите внедрить привычку первое вы
ставите цель второе делае делаете
действия для достижения целей третье
получаете результат или достигаете целе
четвёртое
вознаграждается пятое у вас Повышается
самооценка благодаря этому
вознаграждению и шестое благодаря более
высокой самооценке вы ставите себе
большую цель и седьмое Вы повторяете
весь цикл заново Как сформировать
привычку к достижению
целей первое Не пытайтесь изменить всё
сразу поставьте себе одну маленькую
желательно быстро достижимую цель
например начните с 5 минут утренней
зарядки или чтение пяти страниц книги
всего лишь в день почему сначала цели
должны быть маленькими потому что на
начальных этапах самое важное чтобы цель
была достижимой это самое главное на
этом этапе ваша задача натренировать Вт
лентяя второе совершайте действия в
начале действия должны быть очень
простыми и лёгкими чтобы они вообще не
вызывали у вас никакого внутреннего
отторжения ведь ваша цель - это не стать
крутым сразу ваша цель создать у себя
психологическую привычку достигать целей
третье после достижения цели и
выполнения определённого действия
обязательно водите себя а для этого
Создайте ритуалы
Если вы создадите регулярные ритуалы
Например если вы хотите научиться рано
вставать то Создайте приятный ритуал
утром чашка кофе дымящейся такого
ароматного медитация и лёгкая зарядка
после того как вы встали так ваш мозг
начнёт ассоциировать ранний подъём и
утро с чем-то приятным и он будет
вставать гораздо легче обязательно
похвалите себя ваша задача на этом этапе
поднять свою самооценку
четвёртое Повторяйте весь алгоритм
заново пятое Как узнать что привычка
сформировалась привычка сформировалась
тогда когда вам комфортнее сделать это
чем не сделать например вам же
комфортнее почистить утром зубы чем не
почистить значит это уже привычка А
многие люди задают мне вопрос А сколько
времени нужно для того чтобы
сформировалась привычка есть обще
принятое мнение что привычка формируется
в течение
на самом деле я считаю это не совсем так
потому что я из своего опыта знаю что
некоторые привычки формируются у меня
месяц а некоторые по 5-6 месяцев поэтому
я ввёл для себя другое определение что
привычку Я считаю сформировавшийся
только тогда когда Мне комфортнее
сделать это дело чем его не делать это
более чёткое определение того когда
сформирована привычка с точки зрения
хронологии Всё конечно зависит от того
насколько вы насколько вы
дисциплинирована и как много внимания вы
уделяете ей Поэтому в каждом случае это
индивидуально третий
приём борьбы с прокрастинацией и ленью
ставьте себе значимые цели Вот давайте
подумаем что объединяет великих людей мы
рассмотрели то что объединяет успешных
людей А давайте теперь подумаем над тем
что объединяет великих людей сила воли
дисциплина нет всех великих людей
объединяет только одно Величие цели
Величие или значимость цели - это второй
убийца вашей лени И прокрастинации
именно это и двигает великих людей
великими люди становятся Не сами
великими людей делают их великие цели
если ваша цель значима для вас то вам не
нужны ни дисциплина ни сила
воли смотрите Нет более волевого и
дисциплинированного человека чем человек
которому срочно нужно в туалет Обратите
внимание когда человеку срочно и сильно
что-то нужно он не жалуется на то что
ему это дело не нравится или что у него
прокрастинация лень или нет мотивации он
двигается прямо и на пролом и не видит
препятствий Поэтому если у вас
прокрастинации елень имейте в виду что
скорее всего ваша цель не значима для
вас для того чтобы преодолеть эту
проблему вам нужно либо глубоко осознать
значимость для вас того что вы должны
сделать либо не делать того что для вас
не имеет большого значения например Ваш
начальник сказал вам что-то
сделать по вашему мнению то что Вы
должны сделать очень тупо и не имеет
смысла друзья если у вас так было
обязательно Поставьте лайк этому видео
Да вполне возможно что это так но скорее
всего вы просто не видите всей картинки
поэтому и есть вы долж что-то сделать
спросите у того кто вас просит об этом в
данном случае у начальника В чём смысл
или зачем это нужно сделать а потом уже
оценивайте насколько это нужно Вам
потому что зачастую то что плохо для
одного человека хорошо для коллектива
или для компании и наоборот поэтому для
того чтобы преодолеть свою лень и
прокрастинацию ответьте себе на два
вопроса зачем это нужно сделать И
насколько это важно для вас помни
сначала человек выбирает цель а потом
цель формирует человека четвёртый приём
борьбы с прокрастинацией ленью - это
Создайте окружение которое поддерживает
вас это ещё один важный фактор борьбы с
ленью и прокрастинацией
это ваше окружение ваши друзья коллеги
семья они могут Как мотивировать вас так
и наоборот тормозить ваш Прогресс мы как
известно становимся похожими на тех
людей с которыми мы больше всего
общаемся поэтому окружите себя
развиваются сами и могут помочь вам
расти Вот кстати Именно поэтому на часто
вопрос того В какую школу отдавать детей
я говорю Выбирайте не школу а Выбирайте
среду в которую вы отдаёте детей а
зачастую Бывает так
что В бесплатной школе среда Даже лучше
чем в дорогой какой-нибудь элитной школе
так вот когда вы видите что ваши друзья
или парт двигаются в работают
набо чтото новое это автоматически
мотивирует и вас лень становится слабее
когда все
вокруг что-то делают когда есть
положительные примеры тех кто не
останавливается друзья если у вас есть
большая цель и вы не знаете как её
добиться или как к ней прийти то
обязательно присоединяйтесь к моему
пространству которое я создал специально
для активных людей которые стремятся к
саморазвитию там я собрал все свои
знания инструменты и размышления Если вы
хотите продолжить с саморазвитии вместе
со мной то присоединяйтесь ссылку я
оставлю в описании к этому
видео Итак Подводя итоги лень - это не
что-то что должно управлять вами Это
всего лишь препятствие которые можно
преодолеть с помощью правильных привычек
окружения и небольших но регулярных
действий помните что великие дела
начинаются с маленьких шагов и то что
великие люди становятся великими Только
благодаря тому что у них великие цели
если сегодня начте бороться с ленью
используя хотя бы одну из предложенных
техник вы увидите бешеный Прогресс Не
ставьте перед собой слишком большие
задачи просто начните с малого и
двигайтесь вперёд Желаю вам удачи в
борьбе с ленью и уверен что уже скоро
она перестанет быть вашим врагом а
станет просто очередной задачей которую
вы с лёгкостью будете решать